bella tutti ragazzi è pervenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono felice io oggi sono
dopo molto tempo perciò non facciamo
come iniziare pertanto è un sacco di
tempo con mio papà che può anche non lo
sa ma può parlare è piaciuto è ripetuto
la teniamo già avviene o metti 3 minuto
movimenti tutto allo ragazzi
questo contenuto l'estate prevedere in
collaborazione con la square enix perché
come sapete tutti è uscito final fantasy
vii remake questo video lo sto facendo
con mio papà perché tu hai già giocato a
final fantasy con l'originale quindi mi
sembrava un'idea carina farti vedere
cos'hanno fa 25 anni ipotesi è comunque
si compie uscito il remake di final
fantasy vii io oggi ti faccio vedere
giorni siamo arrivati io questo non l'ho
ancora l'ho giocato già però una demo
però il gioco ufficiale può sopravvivere
adesso la prima volta dico solo che pesa
90 giga secondo me st partano i brividi
perché tutti i ricordi esattamente come
lo ricordo lascirsi però che mettesse tu
pensi che il gioco sia diverso da quello
che stai vedendo la tante incredibili
non è che non parlo c'e nessun senso
appalto non aspetta aspetta aspetta
ecco ecco la guarda guarda qua perché io
ho visto un po di roba
dai ricordi lei come si chiama no non mi
ricordavo sono parole
[Musica]
questo me la ricordo l'accademia di
acerra
ok sì ma non è facile ricordarsi perché
è talmente diversa una certa
[Musica]
madonna va bene no ho anch'io ho avuto
vibes perché si che ci ho giocato però
la la intro così non l'avevo ancora
vista piena e quindi va bene
no
loro 30 dei ricordi forse ti ricordi sai
chi ti ricordi barrett questo qua che
arriva adesso per lui se lo ricordi ha
fatto un po
beh diciamo che non è lo stesso poligono
a circoli nel final fantasy vii vediamo
che lui
va bene ti sei mai chiesto con sorpresa
sta spadavecchia
io l'ho provata l'altra volta e lo prova
mi hanno fatto provare cielo me la
lascio in sovraimpressione ragazzi era
veramente pesantissimo pesanti con sette
chili incredibile proprio mio dio o ci
stanno i cani orc casacca credo tra
l'altro che si possa sbocciare tra due
con belle tra le due modalità di
combattimento con laddove c'è un padrone
che ti queste menate fortissimo poi
quella normale dove invece di manate
normale che è questo
credo che in entrambi i casi sia a posto
adesso poi switch aree su barrett
direttamente praticamente cioè mentre
combatti prince which are agli altri
non so come fai però cambia macinare
gioco ieri 9 mi serve perché devo far
fuori la sentinella perché lui ha il
braccio di ricordi che c'ha la
mitragliatrice entrato nei nostri ho
giocato anche a final fantasy ancora
prima di questo film al quale 5 forse
altri 85 se sì qual è il primo primo
numero di primi ricordo di un final
fantasy che salivano sulle specie se
bianchi e ciò come joe cole
beh sì vabbè in gioco ci sono in quasi
tutti i final fantasy natica paesi in
tutti ma tu hai definito questo mi sono
di noi hanno definito no perché poi
perché è subentrato cui ha poi rubato io
ci ho impiegato io l'ho finito perché
madonna questo ci mettono un ora
praticamente lui pian piano si ricarica
a tempo e tu li puoi sparare
qualcos'altro ha puntato calde morto
ottimo devo usare
ma ton anno cloud è proprio andato giù
sono morto secondo me sono morto lo
stesso probabilmente perso davvero se
claudio andato giù so che ho perso non
posso vincere più magia proprio il prova
giocarla con lui perché ragazzo ha fatto
il culo
sono morto non ho capito ragazzi se per
tirarlo su devo vincere il combattimento
perché potrebbe essere con questo non
sto quasi mandando in stress se la vinco
con barrett già proprio più vulnerabile
subisce motivi danni uso la magia che
cacchio faccio esplosione stremante vai
madonna dai ma che culo sono salvato
all'ultimo dicevo non so se te lo
ricordi ma all'inizio final fantasy vii
ti poteva tipo di cambiare il nome certo
potevi sceglierti il nome io me lo
ricordo bene perché al posto di cloud e
cominceranno tutti quelli che hanno
giocato a final fantasy al posto di
claudia ho cambiato il 9 avevo chiamato
lori c'è io avevo chiamato cloud lori
ora ce l'ho fatto l'ho battuto con
barrett e in tutto questo cloud è morto
è tornato in vita per save sono
praticamente morto un cloud broso
riuscito a sopravvivere al combattimento
quindi tornato in vita con un pil è
meraviglioso ma c'era vivo la posizione
anche la coda di felice ma che pirla
madonna ragazzi dopo morirò tantissimo
se non so se sono quasi morto quad dopo
sono finito per quello che succede tu
non hai idea di cosa è certa non ce
l'hai dopo non ce la farò a fare niente
ci siamo
allora c'è la parte difficile voglio
preparare morirò tantissimo ragazzi però
perché io prima lavoravo per questi tra
l'altro tutto sto casino ultimo miglio
domenti possesso buono pasto da versare
a wise
il suo
un file oppure val d'enza m
io com
27 nel senso il tempo che scorre della
bomba ci dobbiamo finire tutto sto pezzo
in 20 minuti perché sono finiamo in
menti esploriamo pure noi ci avevano 20
20 il temerario
eh già
questo non te lo ricordi adesso sinistra
vigilantes corpo abbiamo perso è stato
bello giocare ragazzi per adesso noi
bellissimo neanche messo venti minuti ho
messo venti minuti anche due sul genio
maledizione penso che la tecnica per
farlo fuori sia la stessa identica
capito come di ufficio per fare luce una
volta nel casino sicuri che credo che
sia la stessa tecnica che ho usato prima
quindi devo farlo andare in sovraccarico
per poi farli più danno però mamma mia
il casinò a merita limite alevita limite
secondo me questa questa non so se ho
fatto bene a usarla adesso con usando
quando intenzione potevi sparare
gli ho levato un po mi ha ucciso non fa
niente sono morto non ho più un modo di
recuperare cloud
devo farlo solo con varie sono morto
sono morto è finita finita oggetti non
ho pilota cosa finisce sono 9 e sono
morte fida lo fanno solo con barrett
demonio porto non mi sia perché non mi
sono spostato quando c'era la cosa sono
uno stupido
raga incredibile non è stato veramente
stupido dai dovrei fare lo stesso anche
se non ha più la tensione teoricamente
spero iddio
nessuno
madonna rega cioè fatta con barre senza
neanche cloud incredibile dopo due ore
due ore di combattimento a posto
no
fatto lui
buono
a è partita adesso hai preso lo si è già
partita di niente
per farlo tu no a posto va bene abbiamo
fatto un casino bar cloud è morto quindi
se non mi prendo una porzione adesso
sono finito totalmente adesso dei
frullati di vita immediatamente a ma che
adesso mancano i venti minuti
adesso io fuggiti qua ottimo no un altro
no ma dopo venti minuti ma un altro di
questi hub è che adesso li facciamo più
in fretta però dalla famiglia dice in
gergo baratro che da solo a carico
ok inizio
[Musica]
bellissima bellissima bellissima
bellissima così si fa perfetto
by è morto
non è morto è morto perfetto buona mano
questa volta l'ha fatta veramente veloce
e perché mi sono ragazzi che ne so io
quando che pian piano inizia a capire se
non ci prendevano subito probabilmente
ancora molte cose le sbaglio quanto
siamo 15
ho voluto usare il pro gay ming modo
e invece l'ho fatta in qua in sei minuti
alla fine anno arrivati al limite quindi
doveva arrivare fino alla io penso di
dover uscire tutto prove
non male
secondo me abbiamo fatto abbastanza
casino ti sta implodendo la playstation
forse no neanche fa
lui e legolas in realtà signori garelli
comune
ho fatto io ho fatto io vado io vado
tutto bene ragazzi e posto non ci voleva
neanche così tanto madonna ok tre
ragazzi questo era il primo che play in
realtà di final fantasy di sfruttate
anche voi il tempo visto che siamo tutti
a caso su final fantasy però che vi sia
asciutto questo era final fantasy vii il
remake ma devi sapere se volete episodio
nei commenti ci vediamo nel prossimo
video ringrazio il mio papà per avermi
accompagnato e per avermi fatto scoprire
final fantasy ai tempi adesso dove ho
fatto scoprire io poi quando faranno nel
remake a la seconda a mio figlio mia
quale hanno fatto un altro remake numero
dei loro di comprare sono mai facili
anche mio figlio lo devo franco migliaio
scegliamo in questo video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]